we believe in those moments we look
forward to those moments we talk about
them we practice them we talk about it
we've been doing it all year so when we
had our chance again we were like hey
we're gonna get this done just believe
sure enough we did
russell wilson after the game there's
something to be said for having
experience
in those difficult moments where you
feel like
you you uh
you can't make a single mistake and the
weight of the world is on your shoulders
and the more you do it the easier it
gets now look it wasn't all that easy
for russell wilson he had that
uncharacteristic interception he's only
had two all year one was a pick six
against the ravens which was an ugly
throw and he tried to to just drop it
right into jacob hollister last night
getting very aggressive going for the
touchdown great interception by the
49ers but but but look all that aside
when it came down to it when he got the
ball back with a minute and change on
the clock it was time for russell wilson
to shine and he had that that run up the
middle you can't give him that much
green space in the middle of the field
he will eventually kill you and he
rumbled for 18 20 yards helped put the
team in field goal range and that was
that chris well yeah i mean it was it
was really not a pretty night for the
seahawks offense i mean they did a good
job a few times of flipping field
position i mean some of the plays he
made he got the ball three times in
overtime i mean you're going wow i mean
can the 49ers really survive giving
russell wilson the ball for the third
time and when they got it back and when
uh this i mean there's just no way
they're the third time's a charm for
russell wilson and some of the plays he
made on the first drive were just out of
this world i mean come on i mean that
was unbelievable you know they were they
were clearly outmatched by again a great
49ers defense we know that i mean just
hey look at look at the drives for for i
mean or how seattle scored points last
night clowney fumble return three play
16-yard drive jacob hollister touchdown
pass for a three yard pass four play 24
yard drive chris carson one yard run so
they weren't unable to really sustain
any drives all night long their defense
is what set them up and it was it was
two great defenses you know early on
you're going
okay the 49ers got control of the game
oh strip sack fumble wow they turned it
over and now they've let the seahawks in
and then the seahawks are controlling
the game and russell wilson you know has
an uncharacteristic turnover fumble and
deforest buckner picks it up and back
comes the pendulum and all of a sudden
the momentum is back on the 49ers side
it just was unreal some of the plays the
defensive players made in this game
there are just so many
beasts on both sides of the ball but yes
ultimately
russell wilson
is the king of doing more with less than
just about anybody in football and it's
been that way for the last three or four
years and he had some moments like that
last night where you just went wow
that's really good chris yeah that's why
he's worth 35 exactly right here that's
right you got you got now now you know i
know and and i don't want it i don't
want you to get triggered i know that
when we start talking about quarterbacks
and hey the contract's up and hey you
know the market's here and you got to
pay him because he's a quarterback a lot
of these guys have a lot of help around
them yes russell wilson doesn't he's the
one guy maybe aaron rodgers is the other
that you can say deserves that money
because they're making it happen without
a lot of help around that's that's
exactly right you know that's what i
argue with you know and again some of
the quarterbacks yeah making similar
money to russell wilson and well i want
to go
all right well when nothing's working
carry your team like russell wilson
because that's what you're being paid
like like another quarterback in the nfc
west i can think of you know but that
doesn't happen you know this is a
special special player i mean he is he's
still it's him in lamar jackson right
now you know as far as leaders in the
clubhouse or the mvp race and uh russell
wilson he's just you know his fortitude
and his just never ending belief in
himself and we're gonna get to get it
done and go hawks and it just he never
breaks character you know some people
think he's a cheese ball i think he's a
cheese ball sometimes and it doesn't
matter and i respect the hell out of
what he does on the football field i
mean he is one of the best competitors
we've seen in the league over the last
10 years
there there has always been that little
hint
and i don't want to say a fraud with
russell wilson it's calculated
it's deliberate total company man it's
it's and and but but who cares yes right
because he delivers right he delivers if
he wants to present himself in a certain
way so be it kid was practicing press
conferences when he was seven years old
that's right there is a manicured
element to what you see and what you get
from russell wilson but you know what
he's in character
all the time that's right does he ever
slip is there ever anything that happens
during a game during a practice at any
time that causes him to be anything
other than the guy that he presents
himself to be at a certain point chris
yeah when you act that way all the time
yeah maybe you become that guy you're
right he is that guy it's not an act
anymore you're right he's just he's it's
like you like michael richards
eventually became kramer like you just
become that guy and i think that's what
russell wilson is he's that guy same
thing with tim tebow he's the other one
who came up in that same time frame
where and that's a little bit that's a
little bit phony that's a little bit
fake but if you do it all the time it
becomes who you are and that's who
russell wilson is now yeah well tim
tebow's got a few cracks in the armor
lately okay so we won't go there right
now but okay anyways either way with
russell wilson you're exactly right and
again i'll just i mean again i don't
want to say again but i'll throw this
out that you're just a phenomenal role
model okay i mean phenomenal i mean you
know my little boy he loves russell
wilson and part of that reason is
because you never hear anything bad
about him always handles himself like a
professional in the podium and the press
conference in public never does anything
bad off the field right got a beautiful
wife he's a baller on the football field
making tons of cash and really does it
all the right way yeah whether we think
it's cool or edgy or not hey that
doesn't really matter it's all about
what he does on the field and he
continues to deliver week in and week
out
he's already got the hall of fame
credentials the question is how much
longer will he keep doing it and he's
told me before he's gonna play till he's
45 and he's only 30. so get ready for
more russell wilson
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports